okay
there's still a few more people coming
in the room so i'll go slow with my
introduction thank you everybody for
coming to jimmy sings press conference
today
and we will start off with remarks from
mr singh and then we will go to
questions reminder to use the raise your
hand function for your question
thanks so much um
today we're calling for an emergency
debate in parliament to respond to the
convoy and to the escalating tensions
that we're seeing we need to see some
leadership and there hasn't been that
leadership at the federal level and so
we're calling for that there's four
things that we want to see happen and
and i'm hoping to be able to use the
emergency debate as a platform to talk
about these four things first of all
we have a crisis on our hands and we
need to immediately have the prime
minister
representing the federal level the
federal government meet with the
affected municipalities to offer any
help that we can to solve this problem
and there is there are serious concerns
going on obviously in ottawa people are
going through
a really horrible situation where the
it's clear that the stated intent of
this of this um
convoy is is to overthrow the government
uh it's in their memorandum of
understanding it's clear they're not
hiding away from it and they are uh
harassing citizens they are threatening
people assaulting people and recent
examples of setting fire to a building
because they're fed up with the noise is
clear this is a violent and dangerous
action that is causing a really severe
consequence to people we also know in
kutz the kudz crossing there there are
truckers that are stuck canadian
truckers that cannot occur across the
border because of the convoy
blocking truckers getting across the
border and these folks are in a really
dire way we know that other cities are
experiencing this as well toronto and
quebec to lesser extents but we first
and foremost need to meet with the
municipalities and and sit down about
what we can do to help uh solve this
problem secondly what's clear and i
alluded to this before that the intent
of this convoy is clear they want to
overthrow the government and now there
is clearly foreign interference there is
there are many examples of american uh
politicians and other folks that are
funding this
direct
um this direct action that is that is
trying to undermine our democracy it's
directly attempting to undermine our
democracy replace elected officials with
unelected committee made up of members
of who knows how they're chosen it is
clear that this is this is not a protest
this is a an act to try to overthrow the
government and
it is getting funded by foreign
interference and we need to investigate
and stop that stop the flow of that
foreign interference particularly coming
from the states
uh thirdly
canadians need a plan to get out of this
pandemic
and and up to this point people were
told well if you get vaccinated we'll be
able to get through this
now lots of people are vaccinated and
they're still
in the pandemic and they want to know
what's it going to take for us to get
out of this
and people need to have that plan what
does that plan look like so
the federal government needs to meet
with public health experts get together
and provide a plan we know that some of
the elements of this plan are going to
include making sure we continue to get
vaccinated and have access to
vaccinations we need to know we need to
get testing and we need to make sure
that we're helping with the emergency
crisis in our health care system because
it continues to push the brink and so
these are some of the elements of the
plan but we need a plan what is it going
to look like for us to get out of this
pandemic how much more is it going to
take and what do we need to do and
people need to know that that's
something that's really important and
then fourth and finally
there are a lot of problems that
canadians faced before the pandemic that
only got worse in the pandemic and we
need to come together as
parliamentarians and work on solving
those problems providing solutions to
those problems there are people that
cannot find housing there are people
that cannot put a roof over their head
nor can they find they don't have enough
resources to pay the bills or or buy
groceries because the cost of living is
going up we need to get together and
start looking for solutions to fix these
problems that people can't find housing
people can
pay their bills people can't afford
groceries so these are things that we
need to do these are four things i'm
outlining as as the reasons why we need
to have this emergency debate and and
what we need to do to move forward to
immediately solve this crisis that we're
in to provide a clear plan to get out of
it and to respond to some of the the
real worries that people have that they
had before the pandemic and it only got
worse during it
[Music]
[Music]
a reminder that if you have a question
please use the raise your hand function
we will do one question one follow-up
off
first question we'll go to alex
ballinger from the toronto star
hey good morning thanks very much um
just wanted to ask you about ottawa
marriage and watson's talking about um
the prospect of having the federal
government appoint a mediator
to talk with the
the freedom convoy protesters
and somehow find common ground what do
you think of that
well we've we've taken the position that
that this is not a group of people the
organizers have made it clear their
intention is to overthrow the government
these are people that are not the
organizers certainly not people that uh
that that we can
have that type of discourse with but we
certainly have have to have to do
something this is an untenable situation
it's clear that things cannot continue
as they are and so the federal
government needs to sit down with the
municipalities in this case with mayor
watson and say hey what can we do to
help to to solve this problem we need to
be open to to whatever possible we want
to obviously look for a peaceful way to
resolve this but we need to we need to
resolve this because it is untenable
uh and and there's a number of elements
that i've outlined that we can do we
need to stop the foreign interference
and and the money that's flowing into
canada that's a big problem and then we
also need to provide a plan i think a
lot of people not this convoy and not
the people there but canadians in
general there are people that are saying
hey like we've done our part we're
vaccinated we agree with getting
vaccinated our families are vaccinated
now what what's it going to take for us
to get through this i think we need to
provide that plan and then and finally
there's lots of things that that people
are really frustrated with not the
convoy but people in general that are
that are real fear fears and worries
like there's people that are that are
obviously vaccinated and are working
hard but they can't afford a home they
can't afford their groceries and so
we've got to provide solutions to them
so those are some of the things that i
think we need to do
just on the foreign interference and on
the the money how exactly do you think
the government i don't know if there's
instruments or mechanisms they can use
to actually block that or do something
or or raise it with with the bible
administration i have no idea but what
what do you think they should actually
do to stop that what you know what
you're calling interference from the us
well some of it is is reaching out to
canadian to american counterparts
absolutely uh our foreign affairs
minister can reach out to
to the the right channels in in the
american government um you know mr
trudeau can reach out to mr biden
president biden and have conversations
there uh but it's clear that you know
it's not really hidden there's on
tweeting out there's attorney generals
from different different states tweeting
out there they're angry at gofundme for
for returning the funds well it's clear
that the funds were being used
inappropriately go fund me made the
right decision there but uh it's clear
that there's lots of foreign money
flowing into canada and it's not flowing
in to support a charity or to support
uh an initiative that that that is a
positive thing they're they're it's
flowing in to support
folks that clearly have expressed their
intent to overthrow a democratically
elected government like that's not a
surprise it's in their memorandum of
understanding on their website the
organizers have made it clear so
this cannot continue and so there's lots
of tools that we have at the federal
level that we need to use to prevent
foreign money being used to interfere
with our democracy
canada
um
a
foreign
um
[Music]
canadian
m
suggestion specifically
foreign
um
next question we have david thornton
from cbc news
[Music]
hi
mr singh good morning thank you so much
for taking my questions it's good to see
you
i'm interested in some of the comments
you said off the top that the other
parties have showed a lack of leadership
or maybe you said specifically the
liberals i wonder if you can expand on
that
a little bit more and what impact that
lack of leadership has had on
this protest
certainly well uh first and foremost the
conservatives are emboldening the
protesters they're going out and meeting
with them saying there's good people on
both sides
clearly evoking that trump language
there is there there have been no uh
protests
in in ottawa that look like this when
there have been
far more people there's not been this
rampant
examples of harassing of citizens of
verbal assaults of physical assaults of
charges being laid by the police even
though they're not actually that
president so many charges are probably
were missed but the the sheer
a number of examples of of hate
of of just desecrating memorials like
all the acts in total do not represent a
normal peaceful protest that's raising
concerns and the fact that all their
efforts are clearly directed at the
citizens they're not directed at
parliament the most noise they make is
when no one is in parliament so clearly
they're they're they're harassing and
terrorizing the citizens of of ottawa
instead of focusing their concern with
with government and government decisions
and and given that the conservatives are
building them by meeting them and using
trumpian language like there's good
people on both sides uh you know clearly
inappropriate uh and then and mr trudeau
has been absent and i acknowledge that
of course he's sick and he's got a a
young one at home one of his children
that's sick but this is like this is a
crisis and and he hasn't been there to
provide leadership and when he has it's
been also to kind of pile on in
inflaming the the tensions as opposed to
providing leadership to solve the
problems and that has all allowed for
this thing to get worse and worse and so
that's that's my concern why i'm calling
this emergency debate is to say listen
we need to provide some solutions we
need to immediately work with the
municipalities impacted offer federal
help we need to stop that flow of
foreign money we need to start figuring
out how we can lay out a plan for
canadians that we're going to get
through this pandemic and there's a lot
of things that people are angry about
before the pandemic things that that
have only gotten worse like the cost of
housing and the cost of living we need
to work together to solve those problems
as well so those are those are things
that that i think need to happen and and
my concern about the lack of leadership
in responding to what's going on right
now
thank you for that i i i do have to ask
about what
you think
what the ndp thinks about
what would be
some of the immediate solutions to end
the situation that we're seeing right
now
and i also have to ask what role does
the military play in an immediate end to
this situation
well i think the first thing is having
that formal meeting with the mayor to
say listen what do we need to do the
mayor and the mayor's team have kind of
more on the ground direct understanding
of the the extent of what's going on and
so that's that's the first step meet
with the mayor offer federal help and
and talk about what we need to do to get
through this uh and then we also need to
stop the the flow of funds that are
coming in i think those are kind of tied
together we meet with the mayors and
municipalities impacted but also stop
the the foreign money and the foreign
influence
uh then in terms of the military
i don't want to see a violent conclusion
to this i want to see a peaceful
resolution and so that that's not the
first step that i think of i think of
other tools that the federal government
could come up with to work in working
with the mayor
but there needs to be some leadership
here and i think
outside of the immediate steps of
meeting with the mayor looking to see
how we can help federally and looking at
what tools we can use and stopping the
foreign aid i really believe the other
steps are very vital canadians in
general are need a plan we need to
provide that plan to canadians of what
we're going to do to get out of this
pandemic i think that's vital i think
it's crucial i think that would take
down some of the temperature across the
country broadly speaking uh not speaking
about the convoy but just broadly
speaking that would be really helpful
and and providing real solutions to give
people some hope people are
are angry
about a number of things again i'm not
speaking the convoy of regular canadians
that have been vaccinated have done
their part are still pretty frustrated
with a lot of things
those those frustrations need to be
solved as well and and we need to be
working together to solve them i think
those are really vital steps
next question we have natasha below from
the national observer
hi thank you so much for taking our
questions
i i wanted to you know sort of clarify
your stance on the language surrounding
this protest
some have referred to it as an
occupation you know insurrection there's
a lot of different
uh terminology flying around how do how
do you characterize it
uh it's wrong
what's what's clear what they're doing
this is not a normal protest there have
been many protests that have happened at
ottawa i've been a part of protests in
the past you know you raise a grievance
with a decision the government's made if
they're cutting helping or if they're
making a bad decision that hurts people
people come together and say hey stop
making this bad decision
that's that's very important very
legitimate and a vibrant part of our
democracy you in those cases you're
directing people direct their concern
towards the people who made a decision
and you're concerned about a specific
decision you focus on that decision or
you focus on a policy and you raise
concerns with the government what's
happening in these in these convoys is
they're actually hurting people they're
targeting people in kutz
truckers who are vaccinated who are
bringing supplies into canada
have been stuck at the border and
initially were stuck for for days
where they were running out of food
running out of water had no access to
the washroom these are working-class
people that are directly being hurt by
these by these convoy people i mean
that's wrong in ottawa
it's the ottawa citizens that are being
terrorized they're being harassed
they're being verbally assaulted they're
being told they can't go out of their
homes and they've got to stay at home
because of risk of violence and we've
got health care workers that are being
told
that these are the type of folks that
are going to harass you and threaten you
don't wear identifiable clothing don't
wear your scrubs
what has happened to get to the point
that the people that care for us that
keep us healthy and safe
are have to be worried and afraid
of their safety
wearing clothing that should identify
them as heroes it's now identifying them
as people that are a target for these
folks so all these indicia to me with
including that the desecration of the
memorials
including all the examples of hate
crimes including the the hate symbols
being waved around these are not indicia
of it just a protest these are people
that are that are engaging in violence
intimidation and directing that towards
citizens that is all wrong and then uh
the
the example that i pointed to the
organizers of this of this convoy are
not hiding the fact they've got a
memorandum of understanding on their
website that clearly states their goal
and a bunch of uh
legal gibberish but it's still their
goal that they want to overthrow the
government the democratically elected
government they want to overthrow it and
supplant it with a committee of people
unelected who knows how they're going to
be determined uh and that as another
example of their goal which is to
overthrow the government
all this points to a very problematic
and and in total a wrong uh series of of
actions that they're taking and so i
would call what they're doing wrong
and hurtful and they're terrorizing and
intimidating citizens and people instead
of what a regular protest does focus on
the government and government decisions
and for all these reasons i think this
is why we really need to take it
seriously and work towards uh a
resolution
thank you and like you said this
this protest for lack of a better word
has displayed some absolutely
abhorrent things that you just mentioned
and
there's no denying that other protests
particularly those by indigenous land
defenders have been met
you know with incredible force from our
police forces across canada with many
recent examples you know in bc but of
course also in the city of ottawa over
the years
what needs to change
on a federal level
to
ensure that that treatment is not
applied to land offenders when
hateful protests like this are allowed
to
flourish some might say in the city
i think i think that term they're
allowed to flourish has been accurate
and i think people are really angry by
that and really frustrated by that that
this flagrant um
ignoring of the laws breaking of the
laws frequently breaking laws uh has
been allowed to happen uh for these
folks and whereas land defenders i ask
this question in parliament i think it's
really pertinent land offenders and
racialized people black community
members when they're raising concerns
around police brutality and the black
lives matter movement or indigenous
communities are just trying to save and
protect their sacred lands they are met
with completely different force and
those are legitimate questions and so
what we've been calling for for a number
of years now we've been working on
at the federal level we can provide
leadership with an overhaul of the laws
around the rcmp how they engage when use
of force is appropriate if appropriate
the criteria and the protocol in terms
of how to work with people and how to
interact with people particularly
indigenous racialized and black
community members and so these are
things that we want to see changed we've
been calling for these changes for a
while now
frankly mr trudeau has not responded to
our our push to get these changes to
happen but we've been doing work in the
committee level and we've been raising
changes that need to be need to happen
and we're going to continue to fight for
that i think there needs to be a
systemic overhaul of the of the
interactions of police with marginalized
people and it's clear in this example
that uh
the the the convoy folks are being
treated completely differently than land
defenders and indigenous communities
racialized and black community members
have been treated in the past when
they've raised real grievances and real
problems and tried to voice those
personnel
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
next question marie wolf with the
canadian press
yeah thank you thank you um
i am
you're talking about earlier about land
defenders and i just wondered if um
since we're on the subject of protest
whether you'd like to comment on what's
happening in what has happened in wet
sweating and i know that there's a large
uh um
petition calling you on you to uh have a
more vociferous response to it um
particularly uh calling on the bc
premiere to stop sending in the rcmp
armed police um and i just wondered
since we're on the subject of protest
whether you thought um this was the time
to say something about that more
possibly more
ardently thank you very much for the
question i've been really clear that uh
seeing
the
use of force of police against
indigenous women and land offenders uh
is not reconciliation and i have long
had a problem with the
the protocols used by the use of force
the policies of the rcap and that we
need to change that that is completely
within the federal government's
jurisdiction we have long call for those
changes we've been calling for changes
for the rcmp since before the black
lives matter protest when people are
raising concerns about police violence
against racialized and indigenous people
we share that concern we are frustrated
with that and we have been calling for
systemic changes to the rcmp to show
leadership that hopefully will influence
other levels of policing because we need
to make sure that there's a different
approach
it is it is hurtful to see the violence
that we've seen we've seen other
examples i shared examples of
of an inukman that was doored by an rcmp
vehicle
of
a chief of an indigenous community that
was violently arrested by our cnp
there are numerous examples of violence
against indigenous people and racialized
people and we can do something about the
rcmp because it's federal it is within
our federal uh jurisdiction to change
the approach to change the use of force
to change the policies and we are
pushing for that we're currently doing
work on it in committee and we're going
to continue to push for changes we want
to see a change to policing and we want
to see a policing that does not
target indigenous people racialized
people black community members with
violence and that has happened too often
yeah on that subject i mean you said you
wanted to see a peaceful solution to
this current protest um but we've seen
you know snipers and armed police does
it concern you that
you know this is a tinderbox and that it
could actually flare up how what is your
ideal resolution to this
ideal resolution one of the things that
could be very helpful is if all
politicians in ottawa state clearly
you've sent a message
time for you to go home now and if we
all say that in a united voice that
would be very helpful right now the
conservatives are emboldening them the
liberals are are using this as well as a
wedge issue i think what we need to do
is
these folks need to go home
and we need to work with the
municipalities to provide help to to
achieve that
we need to also
lay out a clear we need to stop the
foreign money coming in we need to lay
out a clear plan for how we're going to
get through this pandemic that that
would really help
country-wide to address some of the the
frustration that people have these are
the vaccinated people though over 90
percent of canadians that are getting
vaccinated uh we need to make sure that
they know what the next steps are in the
plan is and then we need to make sure
that we're dealing with the problems
that people are living with that have
gotten worse in the pandemic we need to
also do that that's that's also very
very important the housing crisis and
cost of living health care that keeps on
getting to a point of crumbling people
have had their their surgeries pushed
back and delayed people have gotten sick
that have been able to get help because
of the cuts in our health care system
because of the underfunding which has
been a decades and decades of
underfunding so we need to see some we
need to see some real serious steps
taken and i've laid out some of the
steps i think would really help to solve
this crisis and help us move forward
it's going to pass it back to uh
melanie richie and see if there is
i was talking and i was telling you
next question we will go to cormac
mcsweeney for city
news you hear me okay yes sir
excellent
um so you say you want the feds to reach
out to municipalities to find solutions
to this um but the city of ottawa has
been in contact with federal ministers
throughout the protest and
so far no formal requests for additional
resources have been put to the feds
aside from the ottawa police asking the
rcmp for more officers and on foreign
interference the ottawa police have
already said they're working with
national and international agencies to
investigate the funding of this protest
so
i mean these things are already being
done uh so i'm just wondering what
exactly are you calling for that isn't
already being done
that um that could potentially be done
by the federal government to find some
sort of resolution to all of this
i think there's something really
powerful in in the prime minister
meeting with the municipalities uh the
prime minister stating that this is
something that's a priority uh people
have felt like there's been a lack of
leadership people felt like there has
been uh the federal government's been
missing and so
just to have that to have that openly
happen i think would send a clear
message this is being taken seriously
and then uh the the foreign interference
is something that's that's ongoing so we
need to see that escalated so i want to
see
that that taken really seriously and be
understood as foreign interference and
then the the two other steps are things
that we have not seen yet uh we have not
seen the federal government come out
with a clear plan
what is the plan for us to get through
this pandemic we have we have done so
much canadians that have been vaccinated
triple vaccinated are saying well we're
doing our part when are we going to get
out of this what does it look like what
does the end game look like and i think
that's something that's been missing
canadians don't know what the next steps
are going to be and so i think the
federal government has a responsibility
to provide that and that's going to
certainly help in alleviating the
tensions across the country and then uh
and that that plan is going to involve
vaccination it's going to involve
testing and it's going to involve
immediate help to our health care system
which has been at the brink of collapse
and a part of the the frustration that
canadians feel that they can't get the
care they need their loved ones are
being delayed when it comes to the
procedures that's something that we need
to see and then the final piece is there
are a lot of problems that people have
lived with before the pandemic that only
got worse than pandemic and i'm talking
about the housing crisis and the cost of
living and the fact that people are
really worried about what that's going
to mean for them and their families and
i think that's something that we need to
see parliamentarians come together and
work on
but this is a crisis where the federal
government and particularly the prime
minister have not really felt
uh present and that people have felt
like there's a that there's been a
missing leadership and i want to provide
that i also believe strongly that there
has been a
clear attempt to use this convoy by the
conservatives
to
to make it a an opportunity to hurt the
liberals to make it a point
an opportunity to gain points
politically
that is wrong it should not be used that
way and i've seen the liberals also use
this as a wedge issue what we need to do
is provide solutions we need to bring
people together and that's what i'm
hoping to do with the emergency debate
um
now on what the city of ottawa is asking
for this is a bit of a two-parter so on
the negotiations aspect i know you've
already addressed this that you don't
agree with mayor watson's call for
negotiating or assigning a mediator to
negotiate with the group that's behind
this protest um but if if the federal
government decided to accept that
request from the mayor do you have fears
that it could embolden future
demonstrations if they think that
illegal acts and occupying a city is the
way to get their voices heard with the
federal government and then uh slightly
different in the second part some city
councillors are suggesting that the
federal government take operational
control of dealing with the protest
itself despite the fact that this is on
municipal land uh most of this is
happening off federal jurisdiction so is
that something that you would like to
see as opposed to negotiations the feds
taking operational control of handling
the protest itself
i'll start with the second question
first
uh if if the municipalities uh and in
this case if ottawa feels like
the federal level has uh more resources
and and can do
uh can do the work necessary of the
operation control if that would help
then then i think that offer should be
on the table and if that's something
that that will actually assist and we'll
make things better then yeah of course
we should we should look at that um and
that again would be something in working
with municipality not kind of usurping
control but but asking if that would be
helpful and if there's more resources
and and more know-how and if there's a
way for the federal government to be
helpful in that way then that's
something that should be explored on the
first point uh you've outlined some of
the reasons why i'm concerned these
aren't this isn't a group that's saying
and we we have concern with a particular
legislation that's passed um we are
protesting against this legislation that
has been put forward and we need to
discuss how we can improve things or or
we're sending certain legislation uh
this is a group the organizers
particularly have made it clear i mean
these are people that are part of wexa
they want to divide the country these
are people that have put out a
memorandum of understanding that states
clearly their goal of replacing the
elected officials they've got they've
gone as far as to say they would meet
with the governor general and the senate
to set up a committee i mean they're
pretty clear in what they want to do
so meeting with folks that want to
overthrow a democratically elected
government i i don't think is the right
thing to do
in addition i agree that that because of
their behavior the steps taken the the
sheer number of of harassment uh
violence uh desecration uh
hate symbols hate flags like this is not
normal like when people say oh you know
you're drawing attention to
the
some examples
those are not examples that you can
point to in other demonstrations where
they desecrate a memorial where they
harass citizens where they're
terrorizing the people i think that's
not something that happens
any small minority of people doing that
just does not happen that's not that's
not what normal protesters do they
target the government they don't target
the people and they don't flagrantly
continually break laws all over the
place in their goal of terrorizing the
people and so this is this is clearly
problematic you know civil disobedience
is one thing uh when directed towards
the government to raise concerns about a
specific government policy or
legislation but uh to just terrorize
people and break laws to terrorize the
community and citizens and threaten
people and have acts of violence and try
to burn down a building these aren't
just one-offs there's so many examples
of this that it's clearly depicting a
group of people and a culture that's
that's allowing and building this type
of behavior and that's my problem with
uh with trying to mediate with folks
like that that that's emboldening the
wrong sort of uh behavior
and and that's why i got concerns i have
concerns about it
next question we have kevin gallagher
from ctv news
those should be unmuted um
where does the accountability lie here
you've talked about a lot of people you
say are acting or aren't showing
leadership um
you know is this is this something that
the ottawa police should have dealt with
do they have the capacity to deal with
it um you know should the city have
asked for federal help sooner who is
accountable here after what we've seen
over the past uh nearly 11 days
i think i think in retrospect some of
the
some of the the thinking that's coming
out is that
allowing the this convoy to dig in so
quickly so early was was problematic and
i think that could have been prevented
early on but really i think you know
this is the nation's capital this is a
serious crisis and the prime minister
has not been really visible on this and
again i understand that that there was a
covad 19
um a test or a positive test and that
one of his children as well and i
understand that i think that's that's
you know it's obviously a scary and
difficult thing
but uh this is a crisis that demands
leadership and and i think really
fundamentally
that's been where we've seen the biggest
lack of
of leadership that that early on when
this happened there shouldn't be an
immediate offer to work with the
municipality to deal with it
early on there should have been a clear
attempt not to politicize or to kind of
inflame this or to find ways to gain
points on this or create wedges that
this should have been there's a problem
it's impacting people and we need to
solve it uh and there should have been
from the beginning an offer to provide
that assistance federally to the
municipality and and in addition the
other points that i brought up that
people are people are wondering what the
plan is and they need to know what's the
plan to get out of this thing how do we
get out of this pandemic that's a real
question and we also need to know um
that that people are working together
people want to know that
parliamentarians are working together to
deal with
finding some of the solutions to the
things that people are really worried
about like i mentioned the housing costs
and and trying to find a roof over your
head and cost of living these are real
things that that add to the tension in
the country and so these are the things
that i've been calling for and i think
it comes down to it it's it's
the prime minister and the capital of
our country that hasn't been as present
in this crisis as he should have been
a lot of the protesters obviously are
very upset with mandates
um and there are certain some premiers
for example preview jason kennedy who's
considering um
ending the vaccination passport to go to
different you know businesses
but there are public health officials
saying you know before
measures like that
are
taken away maybe hospitalization rates
should fall by say 70
you're saying that
you want this debate to talk about some
of the solutions on the way out um i
think that there
are other canadians outside of the
canadians who have been protesting
parliament hill who are concerned about
government overreach in some way
concerned about
maybe having to face
new vaccination mandates or always
having to show a vaccination passport to
take a plane or a train for example
should there have always been a
discussion as to
what the public health
emergency or crisis
you know warrants
in terms of the future of how these
different restrictions are put in place
i guess what i'm saying is
what would you want to see in terms of
how these restrictions are eventually
loosened because i think most canadians
do want a time when things are more back
to quote
normal yeah i think i think that's that
was my third point this idea of a plan
and i think that
when canadians who like the vast
majority have gotten vaccinated and i
think we're we're about a high rate of
vaccination and we can be proud of that
but people have gotten double vaccinated
have followed the health care mandates
and have been following the rules are
saying well now what like how do we get
through this and i think
what what's been missing kind of
throughout the pandemic has been a clear
path like we need to achieve this
level of vaccination because it's going
to help reduce the pressures on our
health care system and i think i think
some of that that that education or that
awareness providing information was was
missing people people didn't know
uh and i think that really helps if you
say hey
when people are vaccinated they're less
likely to get seriously ill and they
don't end up in the hospital and then we
don't get delays so that someone who
needs a
knee replacement or a hip replacement
can still go in and get that procedure
and we know that a lot of those
procedures have been pushed off a lot of
treatments even even some cancer
treatments have been pushed off and some
diagnoses that could have happened got
pushed off because of a lack of
resources so making it clear that the
vaccination was one to keep you
individually safe but also to prevent an
overflow of our healthcare system and
that's really vital but now people are
saying well what's the next step we've
gotten vaccinated what's the next step
look like and and i think we need to be
looking at
what those next steps are and what does
the future look like and how are we
going to deal with is is cover going to
be a part of our normal life and then
how are we going to deal with that on a
daily basis
one of the things we know for certain is
our health care system should never be
pushed to the brink and that means
making sure we've got stable good
funding so our healthcare system can
deal with
maybe covet being a part of our life for
a long time and so that we're not
worried about
having
a wave increase and then all of a sudden
our healthcare can't deal with it and
respond to it and then we've got to have
serious lockdowns i mean
there is no excuse two years into this
to not not have a clear plan of what a
future is going to look like if it's
going to be a future where cove it's
more likely to be a fact of life then
that how do we deal with that in a way
that doesn't disrupt life with canadians
those are some legit questions and i
think we need a clear plan to lay out
for canadians okay
this is how we're gonna get out of this
pandemic and and get back to a place of
normal
next question we have marika walsh from
global mail
good morning mr singh i'm wondering if
you can explain what you mean when you
say the prime minister has
options at his hands you're you've
criticized him for his absence but i
don't actually understand what you think
he can do right now what are the options
that you see is legitimate and doable
well first off i mean he's been in a
he's been we've been in this crisis for
10 days and he's not really
been present
i think it just makes sense that if
you're the prime minister of canada and
the capital is going through this crisis
prime minister's got to be present in a
crisis like this provide leadership and
and i've said that that formal meeting
with the municipality to say hey i'm
here the leader of this country i'm here
to offer help has a really powerful
symbolic importance like i think that
would send a really clear message that
we're taking this seriously and i think
that that's important um i've laid out
some of the steps that i want to see
happen in terms of how we can bring down
some of the pressure or the tension
canada-wide and i think those are
important things i think having a plan
for how we get out of this pandemic is
really important can't be
uh underemphasized how important that is
people are genuinely
following the rules are vaccinated and
are saying now what and i think that
that plan needs to be there and then the
problem that people are living with i
think the prime minister can deal with
some of this or help us work together
for solutions on some of the problems
that we're dealing with but but a
increased role in in dealing with this
crisis offering all how possible and
there's lots of tools the federal
government has that
what those resources look like and what
those tools are you can work with the
the municipalities to provide that and
then secondly uh that foreign
interference is a really serious concern
and i don't think that it's being taken
at the serious level that it should be
this is a group of people that are
trying to overflow the government
they've made that really clear
and they're being funded by many people
from the states
what is the response to that uh what's
the prime minister going to say about
that i think that would send a powerful
message the prime minister comes out and
says hey this is foreign interference
and it should not continue and
foreign money should not be going
towards supporting a group that's trying
to replace elected officials by meeting
with the senate and the governor general
to try to put in place a committee which
is stated on their website on their on
their memorandum of understandings i
mean these are some serious things and
prime minister hasn't really shown that
leadership and again i gave some grace
for the fact that he's been uh he tested
positive for koga and one of his
children as well this is a you know
verging on 11 days of a serious crisis
in the nation's capital and it's spread
to other cities so there's got to be a
response from the federal government as
well
okay thank you and um
you said earlier that you think that the
police could have avoided this if they
changed their initial approach can you
specify
um
where you see issues with their initial
response to the protest that led us to
this impasse
well i think uh one of the things that's
been raised is that uh when the initial
convoy came in and kind of started
digging in that the initially some of
that could have been stopped and
prevented so that they didn't get to dig
into the levels they did
again that's that's looking back in
retrospect but i think there's learnings
here in the future if we're going to see
a group of people that
are are not protesting against the
government but are going to try to
terrorize the citizens and the community
and the people and that can't be allowed
to happen ever again
people should
protest
uh government decisions whenever they
feel like that's democracy they're
allowed to do that and they should do
that uh but it's very different from
what we're seeing this isn't a a effort
to put pressure on the government as
much as it is an effort to terrorize and
stress
and put pressure on the people and and
their activities at night
preventing people from sleeping honking
all night long this isn't directed
towards the government this is directed
towards people and and there is a
responsibility for
for police services to protect people
from from that type of thing from
happening and i think that there were
some there were some mistakes made in
allowing this to get to this point where
people are constantly being harassed and
and menaced in their own in their own
communities like this is
should not be happening healthcare
workers are being
stressed and not able to to move freely
around their communities i mean that
that should never it should never have
come to this
this concludes our press conference this
is
thanks missy